DR. JAMES GRIME: Yeah, I'm going
to tell you a story, but
what I thought I'd start with
is a little puzzle.
And then while people are
thinking about the puzzle,
I'll tell you a little story,
one of the big legends of
mathematics.
And then we'll see what the
answer to the puzzle was.
The puzzle is fairly
easy to state.
I just want you to add up the
digits from 1 to 1 million.
Now I want you to add
up all the digits--
if you imagine you've
wrote out the
numbers 1 to 1 million.
I want you to add up all the
digits, not the numbers.
So if I want to say 123
plus 124, that's not
what I want to do.
I want to add up all the digits
of those numbers, 1
plus 2 plus 3 plus
1 plus 2 plus 4.
Imagine writing a list of all
the numbers from 1 to 1
million with all those digits,
and I want you to add up all
the digits.
And what answer will you get?
While you think about that, I'm
going to tell you one of
these famous mathematical
stories.
So this is the story of Gauss.
Carl Gauss.
Carl Gauss is possibly one of
the greatest mathematicians of
the last few hundred years.
He really is a really
large figure.
Now the story goes that when
he was nine, he started to
attend, at school, his
arithmetic class.
Now arithmetic class would
include lots of boys, all the
way up to the age of 15.
Imagine, right?
This is 1780 we're talking
about, a long time ago.
Imagine it's a drab schoolroom,
and it's very
worn, and the floor
was uneven.
And the teacher was also drab
and worn and uneven himself.
Apparently he was
quite a bully.
He would walk around with
his cane and he
would thrash the boys.
Now one day, to keep
them quiet--
yeah, this'll keep 'em
quiet for an hour--
he gave them a problem--
to add up all the numbers
from 1 to 100.
So add up all the numbers
So 1 plus 2 plus
3 plus 4 plus--
all the way up to 100.
That was the problem
he gave the pupils.
And they had to write on
slates in those days.
And when you got the solution,
you would put your slate on
the teacher's table.
Now Gauss, when he was given
this problem, immediately
threw his slate onto
the teacher's
table with an answer.
Now the other boys continued
their work, adding up all the
numbers, multiplying and
adding and subtracting,
whatever they had to do.
This brute of a teacher strolled
around the classroom,
throwing just pitying looks at
poor Gauss, this guessing the
answer and throwing
it onto the table.
When the hour was over, he
took the stack of slates,
turned them over so that Gauss's
answer was on the top,
and read out the answer.
To his astonishment, he
got the answer right.
The answer is 5,050.
Which meant that Gauss was able
to solve it in seconds.
How did he solve it?
Well, he had a trick.
The trick was, he noticed
that if you add
the numbers in pairs--
I'm going to start with 1 and
I'm going to add it to 100.
What you get is 101.
Now if you take the second
number and add it to the
second to last number,
99, you get 101.
You take 3 and add it
to 98, you get 101.
In fact, each pair that
you make in this
way would equal 101.
How many pairs do you make?
Well, there's 100 there.
50 pairs, you make.
So he just took 101
and timesed it by
50, and he got 5,050.
So this story was first written
about in an obituary
by one of Carl Gauss's
friends.
Apparently, Carl Gauss would
tell this story himself.
So it seems to be fairly true.
Some embellishments over
the years have been the
brutishness of this
teacher, with this
cane and his thrashing.
That's been added onto
over the years.
The problem I gave you about
adding the numbers 1 to 100,
that's been added onto over
the years, as well.
We don't know what the
original problem was.
So to finish our puzzle
now, maybe
you've got time to think.
We're going to use this method
that, well, Gauss may have
used to solve his problem.
But we were adding the numbers
1 to 1 million.
But we weren't adding
the numbers.
I threw in a twist.
We were adding all the digits
of the numbers.
So let's just write out
the numbers first.
I'll start with 1.
Then I'll have 2,
and 3, and 4.
I'm going to skip a few.
And then we'll go to the end.
Let's go to something like
999,995, 999,996--
getting there--
999,999.
And let's have 1,000,000.
There we go.
Right.
So we were going to add up
all the digits, though.
Well, how about this?
Let's just start with the 0.
I'm going add on the 0.
I didn't say that before,
but let's add on a 0
there at the front.
If I use pairs, 0 paired
up with 999,999--
if you add those together, you
get this number, 999,999.
If you try this pair, we get
the same answer, of course.
And 2 plus this one.
And do 3 and 999,996.
And 4 with 999,995.
And all those pairs equal
the same thing.
Now if all those pairs equal the
same thing, we can now add
up these digits.
And this gives me-- what
does this give?
9 plus 9 plus 9 plus
9 plus 9 plus 9?
54.
And how many pairs
have I made?
Half a million.
Times half a million.
Which is equal to--
it's actually equal
to 27 million.
So all the digits added up to 27
million, except I have left
out my 1,000,000 there.
I didn't add that in
my pair, did I?
So let's add up up those
digits, too.
That is 1.
So we add that on.
And so the answer is, adding
all the numbers--
all the digits of the numbers--
from 1 to 1 million
is 27,000,001, using
Gauss's trick.
MALE SPEAKER: Now at this point,
you can go wild, right?
How many-- how many arrows
do you want?
So the next one, let's say we
did 3 to the power of, to the
power of, to the power--or
arrow, arrow, arrow, or
whatever you want
to call this.
3--
well that, that--